are you Michael yeah how are you I'm  good big night all the Canadian players  are the greatest players  you must be so exciting that you're  gonna raid this place immigration are  gonna breed it lock us all up but yeah  no it's great it's great thrill and I'm  no excited about what seeing a lot of  the guys they I I've never met and guys  I haven't seen since the 80s and yeah  and it's gonna be true no team Gretzky  or team Lemieux they're gonna be coaches  for the alumni game you got to pick one  who would it be  jeez I take Wayne Justin I've known him  more and and and so out of those great  games in the 80s when he obviously with  Edmonton where I was born but um but in  LA where I lived when he came down and  and just tore it up